welcome to the largest and final step in
our journey of Discovery through the
Milky Way with the Hubble Space
Telescope
last time we explored the large
magellanic cloud and discussed how its
gravitational interactions with the
small magellanic Cloud have stimulated a
brilliant burst of star formation in the
Galaxy's largest satellite
such interactions with a variety of
small Galaxies have shaped the past
growth and evolution of the Milky Way's
gas-rich spiral disc and its Stellar
Halo
as we discussed in lecture one the
Hubble image of the spiral galaxy
ugc 12158 provides an excellent example
of what a face-on view of the Milky Way
would look like today if we could view
it from afar
a key question is what will the Galaxy
look like in the future
it turns out that the nearest spiral
galaxy is on a collision course with the
Milky Way
the Andromeda galaxy is moving toward us
at a speed over a hundred times faster
than a rifle bullet
fortunately that's only 0.04 percent of
the speed of light and it will take
quite a while to get here since it's 2.5
million light years away
nevertheless as a result of this
collision and subsequent merger the
shape and character of the Milky Way
will dramatically change over the course
of a few billion years
Hubble has imaged in detail many
thousands of large galaxies beyond the
Milky Way
a number of them have unusual shapes
that are indicative of an ongoing
collision between two galaxies
by combining these individual snapshots
in time with computer models of the
gravitational and hydrodynamical
interactions between colliding galaxies
it is possible to predict the evolution
of the Andromeda Milky Way Collision
one such Hubble snapshot involves the
odd shaped object NGC 2623
located at a distance of 250 million
light years in the constellation cancer
this object is the result of a collision
and ongoing merger of two spiral
galaxies
the sharp Hubble view of the NGC 2623
encounter shows 80 000 light year-long
tidal Tales of stars whose bright blue
color is indicative of the massive star
formation stimulated by the collisional
compression of the Galaxy's gas clouds
in this final lecture we investigate the
spirals in the galactic neighborhood and
explore their future Evolution with the
Milky Way Through Hubble images of NGC
2623 and other interacting galaxies
the two closest spirals to the Milky Way
are Andromeda also known as M31 and the
triangulum Galaxy also known as m33
these three spirals are the largest
galaxies in a galaxy cluster that was
named the local Group by Edwin Hubble
galaxies are typically found in clusters
with memberships ranging from a few to
thousands of galaxies
most of the 60 galaxies in the local
group are dwarf satellites of the Milky
Way and M31
these two spirals are by far the two
most massive galaxies in the local group
the Milky Way M31 and m33 are all within
3 million light years of each other
overall the local group has a radius of
about 5 million light years
the galaxies and clusters like the local
group are held together by their Mutual
gravity
beyond the local group the nearest
galaxy clusters are at a distance of
about 10 million light years
in our expanding big bang universe it is
the space between Galaxy clusters that
is expanding
within a Galaxy cluster or group the
mutual gravity of their constituent
galaxies is strong enough to resist this
expansion
at the same time as the galaxies in a
cluster orbit their Collective Center of
mass close interactions and occasional
collisions between the galaxies are
inevitable
from our perspective on Earth Inside the
Milky Way
M31 and m33 are close together on the
sky
they are separated by a sky angle of 14
degrees or about 28 full moon lists
given the distances of 2.5 and 2.8
million light years to M31 and m33
this angle corresponds to a physical
separation of 700 000 light years
both galaxies appear to the naked eye as
faint fuzzy objects even when viewed
under optimal Sky conditions at a dark
location
a well-equipped camera can improve this
view with an image that clearly shows
that Andromeda is much larger than m33
specifically the spiral discs of M31 and
m33 have respective diameters of about
two hundred thousand and sixty thousand
light years
due to their proximity M31 and m33 are
two of the most well-studied spiral
galaxies
in particular Hubble has recently
invested a lot of observing time into
Imaging them in detail
let's Zoom first into the triangulum
Galaxy
its disk is inclined by an angle of 54
degrees that provides a view mostly
unobscured by dust
the spiral structure of m33 is Loosely
defined by the many pink hydrogen
nebulae excited by hot stars in their
vicinity
unlike the Milky Way there is no obvious
evidence of a stellar bar at the center
of this spiral
it also has a smaller Stellar core with
an upper limit of 3 000 solar masses on
any supermassive black hole at the
nucleus
Hubble has taken an enormous
665 megapixel image of the central one
third of m33
it involves a mosaic of 54 separate
Hubble star fields and 40 hours of
observation time
about 15 billion of m33s 40 billion
stars are visible in this image
overall m33 has about 10 percent of the
number of stars and 5 of the total mass
of the Milky Way
Hubble's sharp view of m33 reveals a
variety of details
a globular cluster stands out in one of
the image close-ups
m33 has a total of about 100 globulars
the bright foreground stars of the Milky
Way stand out in the m33 image due to
their diffraction spikes produced by the
telescope Optics
background galaxies can be seen through
the less Dusty regions of m33's disk
however the most spectacular feature of
the m33 image is the emission nebula NGC
604
this Hubble view of the nebula
accentuates its hydrogen emission it
measures about 1500 light years across
which is 50 times the size of the Orion
Nebula in the Milky Way
it is also 6 000 times more luminous
than Orion the brightest nebula in our
night sky on Earth
indeed NGC 604 is the second most
luminous nebula among all of the
galaxies in the entire local group
only the tarantula nebula in the LMC is
more luminous
the NGC 604 nebula is powered by 200 hot
stars in a 3 million year old cluster
with a total mass of a hundred thousand
suns
this cluster is not quite as compact or
as young as the r136 cluster powering
the tarantula nebula
overall the current star formation rate
in m33 is the equivalent of one solar
mass star every two years
in comparison the current Milky Way rate
is twice as fast with one solar mass
star every year
let's now zoom into the Andromeda galaxy
going from a naked eye perspective to a
sharp Hubble view of one of its spiral
arms we can see that this galaxy has a
much larger nucleus and a greater
inclination than m33
the spiral arms of Andromeda also appear
to be wound more tightly than those in
m33
this spiral structure is most evident in
the dust lanes and the brightest blue
stars
as the Hubble resolution is reached in
the zoom some of these stars are shown
to be clusters
it also resolves out the diffuse glow in
this part of Andromeda as the light of
millions of stars
it is comparable to Imaging a beach on
Earth and resolving out individual
grains of sand
Hubble's gigantic image of Andromeda is
an astonishing 3.9 billion pixels in
size and it covers one third of the
Galaxy's disk it stretches over 60
million light years from the core of
Andromeda to its outer spiral arms
it involves a mosaic of 7 400 exposures
linking 411 separate Hubble star fields
simply put it is the largest Hubble
image ever assembled of any contiguous
part of the sky
indeed it covers a sky area that is
almost three full moons across
overall Andromeda is about twice the
size of the Milky Way and has about
three times as many stars
over 100 million of those stars and
thousands of star clusters are seen in
the hobbled image
this section of the Andromeda image
stretches across forty thousand light
years
the large yellow region of the nuclear
bulge is filled with the light of many
millions of population 2 Stars
there is strong evidence that a black
hole with the mass of 100 Million Suns
resides at the center of this bulge
the large size of andromeda's nuclear
bulge is consistent with it having a
central supermassive black hole that is
25 times more massive than the one at
the core of the Milky Way
another feature of this large-scale
Hubble view is the prominent spiral arm
that circles from the top left to the
lower right
the bright blue stars star clusters and
Associated dust patches clearly Stand
Out across the long stretch of the
spiral arm
let's zoom into the lower part of the
spiral arm with a close-up that spans 4
200 light years
the younger blue stars associated with
the spiral arm stretched diagonally
across the image from the upper left to
the lower right
some of the Dust lanes open star
clusters and star-forming regions making
up this arm are labeled accordingly
moving away from the spiral arm toward
the upper right of the image we see more
exclusively the older redder stars that
are predominant in the disk of Andromeda
in this less Dusty region we also see
distant spiral galaxies far beyond the
stars of Andromeda
in summary the Hubble image of Andromeda
is unprecedented in elucidating such
fine details over a vast region of a
large spiral galaxy
like the Milky Way We Now know that the
Andromeda galaxy has also evolved
through interactions and collisions with
smaller galaxies
its last major interaction was about 200
million years ago
overall the current star formation rate
in Andromeda is the equivalent of one
solar mass star every three years
considered in isolation or with families
of small satellite galaxies large
spirals like Andromeda and the Milky Way
would be expected to maintain their
spiral structure and continue to produce
new generations of stars in their gas
Rich disks for many billions of years
however such galaxies are so massive
that they can dramatically impact each
other's structure and evolution if they
pass within a few hundred thousand light
years of each other during their
gravitational dance in a galaxy cluster
based on spectroscopic measurements of
Andromeda it has been known for some
time that the center of this galaxy is
moving toward the center of the Milky
Way at a velocity of 120 kilometers per
second
a key unknown has been the tangential
motion of Andromeda across our line of
sight on the sky
if this motion is actually larger than
its motion directly toward us Andromeda
will not be coming close to the Milky
Way for a very very long time
on the other hand if its sky motion is
small Andromeda and the Milky Way will
suffer a near-miss or a direct hit in
about four to five billion years
the key challenge in determining the
correct scenario is actually measuring
the tiny Sky motions of Andromeda stars
at its distance of 2.5 million light
years
the Gaia Observatory has recently
succeeded in measuring the sky motions
of a thousand luminous stars in the
Andromeda Galaxy
combined with earlier images of
Andromeda taken with Hubble the Gaia
data has made it possible to better
separate the motion due to the Galaxy's
rotation
from the motion of the Galaxy itself
the resulting tangential velocity of 60
kilometers per second is about half of
andromeda's motion directly toward the
Milky Way
a smaller value obtained earlier with
the Hubble data alone had shown that the
two spirals would pass within a hundred
thousand light years of each other in
about 3.9 billion years
the new Gaia forecast updates the
expected motions of the three spiral
galaxies in the local group over the
next six billion years
it shows that Andromeda and the Milky
Way will pass within 400 000 light years
of each other in about 4.5 billion years
the two galaxies will then separate a
bit more and begin a gravitational dance
that brings them closer and closer
together
in the case of m33 Gaia has been able to
clock its rotation in Sky motion based
on 1500 of its most luminous stars
in 4.5 billion years m33 is projected to
move to an orbital position of 1.6
million light years far from the other
two spirals
let's now consider this future
interaction of Andromeda with the Milky
Way from interwoven perspectives
involving Hubble observations of distant
interacting galaxies
computer simulations of such galaxies
and artistic depictions of the future
night sky as viewed from Earth
We Begin by imagining what the night sky
will look like in about 4 billion years
at this time Andromeda will be nearing
its first close pass of the Milky Way
as a result it will be a huge feature on
the night sky rivaling the entire Milky
Way in brightness
at this point in time the spiral
structure of both galaxies will not yet
have been affected much by the
gravitational interaction
sadly it's unlikely that there will be
anyone on Earth to see this amazing sky
view in 4 billion years
by this time the sun is still a main
sequence star but its Luminosity will
have Arisen by 50 percent compared to
its current value
as a result all of the water on Earth
would have boiled away long before
thereby making the planet a hot lifeless
Rock
nevertheless the Universe goes on
as Andromeda and the Milky Way pass each
other over the following billion years
their gravitational traction begins to
pull tidal Tales of stars and gas out of
both galaxies
at this stage they will look something
like the pair of distorted interacting
spirals known as ARP 273
this beautiful rose-shaped pair of
galaxies is located in the constellation
Andromeda at a distance of 300 million
light years
the Hubble image of ARP 273 measures 230
000 light years across at this distance
the larger Galaxy is about five times
more massive than the smaller one
the distorted appearance of the spirals
in both galaxies indicates that they
recently suffered a close pass
the arms of the smaller Galaxy have been
tidally stretched into tails and a burst
of star formation has occurred in its
core
the outer arm of the larger Galaxy is
now a huge ring with blue bursts of star
formation scattered around it
the Hubble image of the interacting ARP
273 galaxies is thus a snapshot in time
of an initial close pass that has been
playing out for hundreds of millions of
years
at a similar stage the Milky Way and
Andromeda will provide a somewhat
comparable View From Afar
some differences may arise from their
smaller Mass ratio and more distant
first pass
as viewed from Earth after this first
pass the resulting night sky is likely
to feature a warped Milky Way studded
with blue bursts of star formation
the gas and stars and Andromeda will be
tidally stretched across the sky with
ongoing Starbursts throughout
at about the same time the Sun will have
begun its expansion to a red giant star
we are optimistically assuming in this
exercise that Earth survives this solar
transformation and is suitable as a
platform for nighttime viewing by
visiting astronomers
this video clip intermix is a computer
simulation of two colliding spiral
galaxies with Hubble images of actual
interacting galaxies at various stages
in their Collision
it begins shortly before the first pass
with a separation somewhat less than
what we expect for the initial Andromeda
Milky Way interaction
sharp Hubble images are absolutely vital
to refining such detailed simulations
in comparison the ground-based images of
distant interacting galaxies typically
look like fuzzy Blobs of light
a common feature generated by the first
close pass of two large spirals are
tidal Tales of gas and stars
as the clouds of gas in these Tails
collide with one another they can
produce bursts of star formation
by the time of a more direct hit in the
second pass the Galaxy cores are
typically surrounded by a bright
Starburst
the NGC 2623 pair of galaxies is in such
an interaction stage
its Hubble view is what the Milky Way
and Andromeda should look like from afar
in about 6 billion years
NGC 2623 is located in the constellation
cancer at a distance of about 250
million light years
the Hubble image is 240 000 light years
across at this distance with each tidal
tail stretching eighty thousand light
years
this image is the sum of multiple
exposures spanning 2.8 hours of
observing time
it's blue to red color scheme reflects
multi-wavelength observations taken from
the blue to the near infrared
let's zoom into the innermost 60 000
light years of this image
we see the nuclei of the two original
galaxies beginning to merge in the
center
they are surrounded by many bright blue
star clusters that extend into the tidal
Tales
it turns out that the overall star
formation rate in this galaxy merger is
about 20 times that of the Milky Way
induced by many Cloud collisions this
Starburst is rapidly converting the
remaining gas in these galaxies into
Stars
a classic example of a collision
Starburst is a Galaxy pair known as the
antennae galaxies
they are located in the southern
constellation corvus at a distance of 70
million light years
Hubble has imaged the innermost sixty
thousand light years of the antennae at
its highest resolution
it reveals the old yellow cores of two
spiral galaxies amidst the tangle of
bright blue star clusters pink hydrogen
nebulae and brown dust clouds
among the Thousand massive Young Star
clusters identified in this image
about a hundred are compact enough to
eventually become globular clusters
like the previous example the overall
antennae star formation rate is also
about 20 times that of the Milky Way
based on these two cases the entire
night sky is viewed from Earth in about
6 billion years will be like the best
fireworks display that you have ever
seen
best of all it will last for many
millions of years
as Andromeda and the Milky Way Collide
directly it will take that long for
their gas to be consumed by the
resulting Starburst
locally the sun will be evolving from a
red giant to a white dwarf
given the vast star spacing in the two
galaxies it is very unlikely that the
planetary orbits in the solar system
will be disrupted by their Collision
in this video simulation we View From
Afar the expected motions of the three
spirals in the local group from the
present day through the initial close
passive Andromeda with the Milky Way to
their final merger
note that all three galaxies appear blue
originally due to their continuing star
formation and production of massive
young stars as separate spirals
as Andromeda and the Milky Way Collide
and merge over several billion years
their Interstellar gas is completely
consumed by a starburst the young blue
stars all die off with no continuing
Replacements not possible and the merged
Galaxy ends up with the yellowish color
of an older system
note that m33
continues its star formation and
maintains its blue color as it orbits
far from the other two galaxies
the Milky Way Andromeda merger finalizes
in about 8 billion years with the
product looking like an elliptical
galaxy
m49 is an example of such an elliptical
it is located at a distance of 56
million light years and has a width of a
hundred and sixty thousand light years
the Hubble image of its innermost 50 000
light years is mostly featureless except
for a bright nucleus
this nucleus Harbors a central black
hole with a mass of 500 million Suns
overall m49 has more than 200 billion
stars and 6 000 globular clusters with
an average age of 10 billion years
its last major star formation episode
was six billion years ago it has little
Interstellar matter now
m49 is a member of the Virgo cluster of
galaxies
this Rich cluster contains more than a
thousand galaxies
m49 formed long ago from multiple
collisions of gas-rich galaxies in the
cluster
ancient Starbursts consumed all of the
interstellar matter in m49 and forged
its many globular clusters
in contrast are much sparser local group
of galaxies has allowed its gas-rich
spirals to last longer
now that the future of the Milky Way and
Andromeda is clear
names like Milko media have been
proposed for the merged elliptical that
is destined to become
of course we all want to know what will
be the fate of the solar system as a
result of this merger
there is about a 10 chance that it will
be thrown on a tidal tail into extra
Galactic space
it is less likely that it will be thrown
near or into the merged supermassive
black hole at the new galactic center
due to the vast space between the stars
there is essentially no chance that it
will collide with a star from Andromeda
thus most likely it will be thrown into
a large elliptical orbit around the new
galactic center
imagine the night sky view on Earth from
such a future solar system in about 10
billion years
the diffuse band of light across the sky
from which the Milky Way got its name is
now gone
instead there is a bright glow in one
part of the sky towards the new galactic
center
few billion years after this time there
will be some brief minor excitement when
m33 merges with the now established
milkometer Galaxy
otherwise this will be the nighttime
view on Earth for the next 100 billion
years until the tiniest Stars Burn Out
in summary the Collision of the
Andromeda galaxy with the Milky Way will
be a transformative event that changes
the very essence of our night sky
through our exploration of the Milky Way
with Hubble in this course we have seen
that it is a vast star making machine
whose spiral structure stimulates a
dynamic process that has been recycling
matter between stars and the
interstellar medium for the past 13
billion years
we have also seen how interactions
involving nearby star systems such as
the magellanic clouds can stimulate
Starbursts that more rapidly consume the
interstellar gas in a galaxy
but collision with Andromeda will
essentially consume the remaining
star-making potential of the Milky Way
over the course of three billion years
20 billion year adolescents of our
galaxy as a spiral will end and it's
much longer life as an elliptical will
begin
fortunately we live at a time when we
can still Marvel at the naked eye view
of the Milky Way stretching across the
sky from the remaining dark places on
Earth
I hope that you have enjoyed this
opportunity to explore the wonders of
our galaxy through the sharp eye of the
Hubble Space Telescope